congratulations to all right winner has
it hit you yet have you processed it can
I believe in like I was just in the
house like an hour ago but I'm grateful
for the result and I'm really grateful
for Ricki for taking me and it's a big
dream come true to be honest yeah
because you were a Big Brother fan
before you got to play Big Brother and
you know you broke a curse tonight I did
because you you're the first person to
ever walk into the house first and walk
away with the title oh that's a big deal
oh that's great I didn't even lift there
I didn't plan any of this all of this is
God's plan and you know it's it's just
amazing it's amazing to be here first of
all was amazing to be picked in the
house
the Big Brother house and to come out as
the winner is just like it's
life-changing for me I loved your little
boy ran right up on stage as soon as you
got out there
I mean life keeps going while you're
stuck in that house I always like to see
him oh man it was such an amazing moment
I've dreamt of that moment for 30 days
and it was just like I dreamt he's so
big now and Logan always makes me laugh
and you know that didn't change tonight
I'm just really happy and grateful to be
his mom all right it was a unanimous
vote for you you got all of them did
that shock you can you believe that part
yes that is shocking I mean I have a
unanimous first of all that's a big deal
for any Big Brother watcher a fan
anybody was in the house like it's just
it's a blessing on top of a blessing you
know that really means that my
friendships in the house are really real
and I'm really grateful for that too
because I really like everybody yeah and
we love we got to watch you and kandi
reconnect bury the hatchet she was
saying it was so many little things that
had built up over time that there wasn't
one thing you guys could pinpoint to and
it was a lot of arguments with many
conversations but to help us through it
and you know what sometimes you have to
go back and revisit the path and
kind of hash it out so you can get a
clear understanding esta oh I'm so sorry
I didn't know that hurts you and
apologize and move on and that's how we
got through it we both really wanted to
did you expect there would be so much
healing in the Big Brother house no I
did and you know and in my bedroom
Alliance we like to call it alone was so
magical and so amazing we've been able
to have some real heart-to-heart
heartwrenching real conversations that
I'll take with me forever all right we
are goes one of them she's so beautiful
I'm so good you're so beep all right a
big story other than your win is you
guys trying to help Deena Court like get
through this whole catfish situation
he's a real guy they tracked him down
yeah and I'm really excited for Mama
Deena I'm she deserves happiness she
needs a husband and that's awesome
you know I missing you my mom out
because I'm looking for stepdad too and
so she says he's a great guy and I'm
grateful to all that he's real yeah
all right we are having everybody leave
questions for each other tonight and
Kandi's question that she left for you
was will you get on a group text with
everybody after this I'm gonna have to
pray about dad because I think other
people is gonna text more than others
but I will include our in our bedroom
chat how about that one room and go from
there chances are they're gonna do
another season of syllabic brother they
should what's your number one piece of
advice for the next batch of stars to
move in oh this is not cliche darling
expect the unexpected
absolutely absolutely you know we got to
catch up with your sister Tony while you
were in the house show her the message
you recorded she said it was like you
Earl in jail because she couldn't get
ahold of you she looked beautiful I saw
I thought that the clip not too long ago
and I'm just so happy for my sister you
know I can't wait to see her
yeah now the last time I talked to you
was when Bluebird of happiness came out
did being in the Big Brother house
inspire any new music could we get
another record actually did you know
this is the longest that I've gone
without singing it's like 30 days and
with Joey being in the house and he's a
whole boy band by himself he's
definitely inspired me and being in the
house inspired me to write and to keep
moving forward with my music career
going back on calling Bluebird of
happiness to the final album are we
gonna get another album album maybe an
EP you know the music industry has
changed a whole lot you know but
definitely new music for sure alright
yeah and then are we headed back to
reality TV are we getting another season
of Braxton Family Values my hope is to
be the car to be a TV are we gonna get
to see your mystery man on Braxton
Family Values is still together still
happy with him I hope so you know and
he's like a regular in the business so
he's probably tired of my shenanigans by
now um I don't know that like we had
something really really special he's a
he's a great guy and my son really likes
him a lot and yep wrap things up here
one word to describe your big brother
experience excellent a one word so many
amazing crazy grateful bomb all the
things you guys 250k and you're buying a
house I can't believe I've never want
anything okay including a Grammy and I
wasn't I wasn't Celebrity Big Brother
big deal I'll take that very big yes it
is
[Music]